bonjour bienvenue dans europe hebdo nous
sommes à bruxelles au parlement européen
pour 30 minutes d'actualité européenne
alors dans cette émission nous allons
nous pencher sur les blocages français
marché du travail réforme des
institutions renouvellement de la classe
politique pourquoi la france passe pour
être irréformable à l'heure où des
centaines de milliers de personnes
défilent tu à paris et dans les grandes
villes françaises contre la loi sur le
travail de myriam el khomri nous allons
donc nous pencher sur ce mal français
l'immobilisme mais avant d'en discuter
avec mes invités retour sur les
dernières manifestations a tout de suite
sous une pluie battante ils sont entre
400 mille et un million deux cent mille
à battre le pavé dans toute la france
objectif le retrait de la loi elle
conneries sur le travail
on ne lâche rien tout à fait on ne lâche
rien parce que c'est trop grave
c'est une rupture par rapport au modèle
républicain de la négociation collective
dans notre pays à l'instar de ce qui
s'est fait dans d'autres pays je pense à
l'allemagne je pense à l'espagne au
portugal
côté gouvernement l'heure est à
l'apaisement
quoique qu'il y ait de l'exaspération
dans un pays où il ya un chômage de
masse depuis trente ans et que ces
inquiétudes s'expriment bien évidemment
il faut rester à l'écouté
même si l'opinion publique ne peut pas
être la seule boussole de l'action
gouvernementale
après plusieurs semaines de bras de fer
entre étudiants lycéens leaders
politiques de gauche et les
syndicalistes le mouvement social risque
bien de s'amplifier là aujourd'hui il ya
des occupations
ça prouve que l'on s'arrête pas après la
manifestation voilà c'est tout ce
mouvement là par rapport à la loi
travail qui est en train de naître et
les occupations de places bien entendu
que pour nous c'est aussi une tentative
par rapport à ce qui se passe en espagne
en grèce occuper la république depuis la
manifestation du 31 mars le mot d'ordre
est lancé on a une sorte de fenêtre
qu'on veut exploiter pour remettre en
cause le système néolibéral et ses excès
remettre en cause le système néolibéral
à l'image de podemos en espagne où
syriza en grèce un rêve général
alors pourra-t-on espérer voir un jour
ce rêve général se réaliser c'est la
question je vais poser à mes invités
pervenche berès bonjour vous êtes
députée européenne membre du groupe
socialiste et démocrate bienvenue à vous
à côté dit vous pascal durand bonjour
donc député européen vous êtes membre du
groupe des verts est en face de vous
jean quatremer journaliste au quotidien
libération vous êtes le spécialiste ici
des questions européennes alors
pervenche beres âge mais je m'adresse à
vous d'abord on voit que les places las
on commence à être occupé notamment à
paris le mouvement s'amplifie un million
de potentiellement trois cent mille
selon la police dans les rues finalement
on va au blocage
je ne le souhaite pas et si on veut le
rêve général c'est sûrement pas un rêve
de blocage et c'est peut-être la
manifestation qu'il ya des choses qui ne
marchent pas bien dans notre pays et où
en tout cas il ya eu un sentiment de la
jeunesse de courir après des mythes
qu'on n'arrive pas à atteindre et c'est
peut-être le signe plus profond je crois
de ce que notre pays a du mal à se
réformer
accepter une certaine forme de modernité
alors selon vous ces jeunes là qu'on
voit dans la rue sont des gens pas très
moderne ne peut être pas bien ce que
j'ai pas dit jeudi qu'ils étaient à la
recherche d'un idéal et du sens à donner
à leur vie à leur engagement et une
inquiétude par rapport à l'évolution de
la société par rapport à leur rôle futur
simplement il faut aussi s'interroger de
savoir qui ces jeunes représentent et à
quoi il aspire profondément la presse
ces jours ci etc remplies de papiers qui
me disent mais au fond que veulent ces
jeunes de la place de la république
parce que on voit bien que la question
de la réforme de la loi du travail
c'est peut-être un sujet mais c'est pas
le sujet fondamental qui explique ces
soirées place de la république alors
selon vous jean quatremer sais quoi qui
explique ces soirées place de la
république c'est une envie plus globale
de renverser la table
en tous les cas je m'interroge sur le
sens profond de ce de ce type de
mouvement parce que je remarque la
dernière mobilisation de la jeunesse
et du monde du travail des citoyens
français pour des valeurs c'était en
2002 lorsque jean-marie le pen s'est
qualifié pour le second tour 21 avril et
donc la manifestation du 1er mai y
sommes absolument
donc là on a vu des gens défendre des
valeurs un modèle républicain
ensuite ça a été des manifestations
depuis c'est le cas des manifestations
pour défendre le statu quo surtout ne
changez rien
donc ça a été la lutte contre le contrat
première embauche cpe
ça a été la lutte contre la réforme des
retraites est aujourd'hui la lutte
contre la réforme du travail au moment
même où par ailleurs l'europe est en
train de se transformer en forteresse où
on est en train de renvoyer vers la
turquie al pays très démocratique
comme vous le savez très bien des
centaines voire des bientôt des milliers
des dizaines de milliers de réfugiés que
des gens seulement en méditerranée que
nous nos états sont en train de se
transformer en état autorisons manifeste
pas pour les bonnes raisons selon vous
on ne manifestaient pas pour les bonnes
raisons et en plus ceux qui manifestent
mais là c'est facile en ce sont des
lycéens et des étudiants
c'est à dire des gens qui ne sont pas
touchés par le chômage de masse mais qui
ont du mal à rentrer sur le marché du
travail mais tout le monde je viens moi
j'appartiens à une génération moi je
suis la génération post 68 j'ai eu du
mal à rentrer sur le marché du travail
j'ai enchaîné les stages les vacations
etc c'est il ya un ami mais non il y
avait dans les années 90 mais je suis
rentrée sur le marché du travail
à la fin des années 80 je suis désolé ça
ne fait pas plus simple c'était
difficile car est un mal français fin et
quand on regarde les statistiques du
chômage en exemple pour les gens qui
sont formés et quand je parle pas des
gens qui ont un diplôme en sociologie là
il peut se faire du souci effectivement
mais pour les autres le taux de chômage
sont aux alentours de 4 5% hier que ces
gens là effectivement que le diplôme
protège du chômage mais drame français
c'est en réalité le système scolaire
il produit de l'échec en masse et là
vous avez donc là selon vous le problème
c'est quoi c'est qu'on a affaire à une
jeunesse qui cherche à renverser la
table parce qu'elle en a ras-le-bol du
système ou plus globalement c'est
vraiment la loi elle comrie qui pose
problème
écoutez quand j'entends des jeunes dire
dénoncer le système néolibéral dans le
pays
dans la dépense publique est de 58% ou
aucun poste de dépenses sociales n'a été
réduit depuis 25 ans j'avoue que ça me
sidère un peu alors sera aussi amené au
libéral si on était au niveau peut-être
des dépenses
public britannique voir américaine la
france est le pays le plus socialiste de
la planète ce cas lioran qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
exactement la même chose mais ça vous
étonnera pas c'est pour ça qu'on est con
invité d'abord la première chose
j'entends pervenche berès lorsqu'il dit
que ces jeunes cherchent un idéal je
vais être un peu plus pragmatique qui
cherchent d'abord du boulot et cherche
des formations il cherche à trouver leur
place dans une société qui les laisse
complètement dehors c'est vrai pour les
jeunes mais pas que
c'est vrai dans certaines villes c'est
vrai dans de manière générale on a
l'impression que l'arrêt plage du
premier cdi 28-29 alors justement
j'allais le dire parce que et c'est vrai
ce que dit jean quatremer sur le fait
que ça a été dur à d'autres périodes de
la vie peut-être la vôtre
sauf que moi je vois et je le vois par
rapport à mes enfants par exemple
maintenant on leur propose qu'ils soient
diplômés ou pas et ils sont diplômés
mais d'abord et avant tout des stages
c'est à dire qu'à 25 ans ou à 26 ans on
est encore à proposer à des jeunes qui
le sont de moins en moins des métiers
précaire des 450 euros ou 500 euros qui
leur interdit d'avoir une vie autonome -
26 ans il se trouve que j'avais déjà mon
premier enfant et que je venais de
prêter serment pour être avocat
donc on avait une capacité d'entrer dans
la société d'entrer dans la vie qui
n'existe plus maintenant donc d'abord et
avant tout c'est la manifestation d'un
d'un sentiment d'être écartée d'être
mais est ce que c'est un spécifiquement
un mal français on parle de
flexisécurité en europe d'une capacité
en fait par un mal français lilly a une
il ya dans d'autres pays alors peut-être
parce qu'il ya eu d'autres conditions de
travail donc ça c'est un autre problème
la question de réformer le droit du
travail
ça c'est un autre sujet mais ils ont la
capacité de trouver des jobs est pas
nécessairement des stages comme en
allemagne ou en angleterre qui ont ces
pays que je connais bien les jeunes
troupes des mangas mange bien après des
stages ou des apprentissages de
qualifiant d avancée très important de
bien faire les comparaisons
internationales et notamment européennes
parce que on a la foi parfois
l'impression que la france serait le
pays malade de l'union européenne moi je
regarde franchement aujourd'hui le pays
l'union européenne
je connais pas de champion toutes
catégories
les pays de l'union européenne ne vont
pas très bien ils sont bousculés par
beaucoup de choses
il ya une interaction entre leur
impuissance à l'échelle européenne ont
leur propre impuissance face aux défis
auxquels ils sont confrontés et dans la
mondialisation el fellah tôt je crois
qu'on sera d'accord pour dire que raison
de plus pour actionner le levier
européen mais notre capacité de
convaincre
pour l'instant on a encore des marges de
progression mais sur le défi que
rencontrent ces jeunes je parlais d'un
idéal parce que moi je me souviens quand
j'avais leur âge j'avais quand même la
vision d'une société où chacun de
trouver sa place et avait 100
l'impression de contribuer à un projet
commun avec cette idée d'un projet
commun c'est quand même quelque chose
qui continue à un email nous sommes et
il s'agira mais elle est confrontée à
des choses qui sont communes à toutes
les jeunesses d'europe et à nos
spécificités dans nos spécificités par
exemple la question de la place du
diplôme feu est une question absolument
majeur ce que disait jean quatremer vous
allez au royaume-uni alors au royaume
uni tout les jobs qui sont offerts à des
jeunes ne sont pas assez rémunérés
toujours etc
mais cette disqualification au nom du
diplôme n'existe pas et c'est une des
difficultés que j'ai avec cette réforme
c'est que je pense qu'il y avait enfin
il ya matière en faire une immense
réforme de gauche ils avaient leurs bras
lors dès lors qu'on en fait
la réforme du compte rendu du compte
personnalisé d'activités qui échangent
les limites de contrat social finalement
et englobe baïkal le lac estion
l'éducation la confiance à genève mais
moi j'ai un gros maire je rebondis sur
ce que disait pascal durand
effectivement c'est il faut ce qu'il
faut regarder l'ensemble du système
quelle est la difficulté des jeunes
aujourd'hui vous trouver un petit boulot
ou un boulot qui est pas très bien payé
au départ le problème ensuite se
trouvait à logements de d'avoir des
garanties de trouver un crédit bancaire
d'avoir des 40 x et aurélie c'est pas
possible c'est de l'eau du système
limbique et qu'est ce qu'on a fait par
exemple au canada c'est très intéressant
pour garder le canada en 95 le pays
était en faillite
là on a pas on n'a pas mégoté parce que
c'est un pays plutôt tadis anglo saxon
on a coupé à mort dans les budgets
sociaux
mais qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a enlevé
par exemple les haies
qui allait aux plus riches sont
familiales des plus riches et on l'a
divisé leur montant par deux et on a
tous réorienter vers des classes les
plus pauvres
le résultat c'est qu'aujourd'hui au
canada c'est le taux d'illettrisme pas
dans la politique d'illettrisme le plus
bas du monde occidental
de même sur le logement qu'est ce qu'on
a fait on a libéralisé complètement le
logement c'est à dire que lorsque vous
ne payez pas votre loyer vous êtes viré
votre logement en deux semaines berne à
la bollywood
le résultat c'est quoi ouais c'est à
dire que vous vous et votre logement à
n'importe qui vous demandez pas des
gares ou les garanties légales etc
j'ai effectivement aussi le cas vous
dites je m'engage à payer moins et puis
vous trouver les moyens ce qu'il faut
faire
moi je voudrais alors mal à rebondir je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec jean
quatremer c'est là dessus je partage à
100 % pour le crédit s'est parallèlement
il on aurait pu on pourrait imaginer en
france une garantie des loyers pour les
étudiants pour ceux qui n'ont pas la
capacité parce que les parents etc etc
mais moi je voudrais quand même revenir
sur une des raisons du blocage
j'entends le fait qu'on a du mal à
réformer mais comment se fait-il
comment se fait-il que la gauche arrive
au pouvoir après des années avoir
critiqué le gouvernement et à juste
titre notamment de nicolas sarkozy et
elle arrive au pouvoir
et on attend la quatrième année c'est à
dire quasiment la fin du mandat du
président de la république et du
gouvernement pour réformer le droit du
travail comment se peut-il alors que
c'est une priorité pour la gauche que le
président de la république avait dit
l'emploi des jeunes notamment et la
priorité des priorités et il avait
raison de le dire et je sais que
pervenche berès fait beaucoup en europe
avec loupe pas seul mais pour faire en
sorte la garantie jeunesse etc
comment se peut-il c'est ça le problème
de la france est de me dire que on
arrive au pouvoir
on a l'impression que soit on n'est pas
préparé à à réformer donc ça c'est la
faute de la classe politique il devient
manque pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas
utilisé la première ou la deuxième année
à faire et voilà que la france est
dirigée par lafarge et dirigé par des
fonctionnaires
qui ont des scénaristes ont de tels
avantages qu'ils se posent pas la
question
et surtout il répond non mais d'abord je
verrai ce on peut pas non plus dire que
rien ne s'est passé parce que je deviens
laurier maillage marcos madrid
physiquement 4 par exemple sur la
question de l'investissement faire en
faveur de l'éducation
je ne dis pas que tous aient transformé
par des investissements qui sont
immédiatement avec des résultats
nous restons un pays totalement
paradoxal on est le pays où les enfants
rentrent les premiers à l'école dès
l'âge de deux ans on est les champions
d'europe pour ça même si le chiffre
baisse est à l'autre bout de la chaîne
on est les champions de ceux qui sortent
sans qualification
il ya un volet qui moi me semble très
important c'est que aujourd'hui avec le
fonctionnement de la démocratie avec le
fonctionnement des médias
la question du dialogue social devant
une question absolument majeur alors je
ne sais pas si c'est une question
institutionnelle je ne sais pas si c'est
lié à la nature des syndicats je
n'accuse personne on est dedans ça mais
je vois bien qu'une réforme de cette
nature si elle n'est pas portée par un
profond dialogue social qui lie digues
et qu'il a pas beaucoup
on en arrive à un blocage et c'est
effectivement ce à quoi on assiste
d'ajustement peut-être que ça va nous
ouvrir encore plus sur un autre blocage
français qui est du coup le peu de
renouvellement de ses élites et et donc
de sa classe politique et donc de sa
classe syndicale et cetera exactement ça
va avec donc on a été voir chez le
voisin suédois
comment cette politique s'organise cette
politique de renouvellement c'est un
reportage de solenn nicolas est un
montage de yoann loiseau
c'est un modèle dont on vante la
réussite
le fameux modèle scandinave en suède une
monarchie parlementaire
le système politique met le citoyen au
centre des décisions cet après midi à
l'hôtel de ville de stockholm
lorenzo vat 26 ans presse le pas le
jeune ténor de la politique suédoise est
attendu à la réunion de son parti les
verts
l'objectif préparer le prochain conseil
municipal
à l'ordre du jour le trafic dans la
capitale suédoise et autour de la table
la moyenne d'âge n'est pas très élevé
ici on a vraiment ce sentiment d'être
plus intelligent quand on est avec des
gens différents de nous si tu es jeune
tu as ton mot à dire
tu as forcément des compétences à
apporter et c'est bien ça le but de la
démocratie représentative incarner la
société dans sa diversité
s'il est l'un des jeunes visages du
paysage politique suédois
lawrence thauvette est pourtant loin
d'être un novice on sent un porte-parole
des jeunes verts il s'y ajoute
aujourd'hui au conseil municipal de la
capitale
une ascension qu'il attribue notamment à
ce modèle qui facilite le renouvellement
et l'accession des jeunes à la vie
politique
c'est plutôt facile en suède d'entrer en
la politique ce n'est pas quelque chose
que tu apprends ça doit être une chose
en laquelle tu crois profondément
paul shin devine scrutin proportionnel
et consensus sont les clés de ce modèle
qui allège les devoirs du citoyen quand
un français doit se rendre dix fois aux
urnes
un suédois ne s'y rendra qu'une seule
fois résultat aux dernières législatives
un taux de participation de plus de 83%
une régulation plus simples de la vie
politique et une conception anti
élitiste de l'exercice du pouvoir
l'actuel premier ministre
syndicalistes de longue date et soudeur
de métier qu'est ce qui fait l'homme
politique il est façonnée à travers des
expériences collectives
je pense le syndicat sans lui mais on
est dans un pays où le taux de
syndicalisation approche chez 80% n'y a
pas de d'école qui façonnent les élites
politiques vous avez des cursus de
sciences politiques mais vous n'avez pas
de l'école nationale d'administration du
produit en fait d edith avec des
discours parfois parfois semblables
m
aïda dial hic est l'un des symboles de
son modèle et de l'état providence
suédois
ma vie a débuté avec la guerre la mort
les camps de réfugiés et beaucoup de
pertes humaines
engagé en politique à 16 ans vice maire
d'une ville suédoise à 23 elle est l'un
de ces exemples de personnalités
politiques issues du terrain en 2014
elle devient à 27 ans la plus jeune
ministre de l'histoire de la suède qui
pour la plupart des gens ne me croient
pas quand je leur dis que je n'avais pas
prévu d'être à cette place aujourd'hui
quand je me suis engagé en politique
cependant je ne pense pas faire de la
politique
toute ma vie je crois que les gens qui
restent trop longtemps en finisse par
être déconnecté de la réalité
nous avons une formule en suédois qui
est neuf blocs
ça signifie que c'est une mission ou te
confie on a confiance en toi
si cette confiance tu dois la mériter et
gardez en tête que c'est temporaire
en suède si on entre tout en politique
on reste aussi souvent moins longtemps
au pouvoir
représentativité proximité avec les
citoyens
le modèle social-démocrate suédois a
aussi été forgé par les mouvements
féministes aujourd'hui au parlement
les femmes sont presque aussi nombreuses
que les hommes pour caroline et nice
étudiant en sciences politiques il reste
cependant des points à améliorer
lors de la campagne interne du parti
dans lequel je suis engagé une femme
s'était portée candidate
et il y avait eu de vives discussions
ont tout fait
cette femme représentait le parti alors
on pourrait perdre beaucoup de votes
masculins
le modèle politique suédois dont le
scrutin proportionnel et le consensus
force parfois les parties à des
coalitions a été remis en question 2014
la formation du centre droit s'était
alors allié à l'extrême droite
la suède doit faire face aux mêmes
nombreux défis que les autres pays
européens
son système de renouvellement est donc
précieux dans le contexte actuel alors
peut-on imaginer importer le modèle
suédois en france jean quatremer vous y
croyez est-ce que c'est impensable
d'imaginer qu'une femme de 23 ans
si de réfugiés soit un jour maire d'une
ville de 50 mille habitants à 23 ans
non ça c'est pas totalement impossible
honnêtement d'ailleurs on l'a bien vu
ne serait-ce qu'à paris avec quelqu'un
comme delanoë ya qui aurait pensé que la
loi sur un jour maire de paris il avait
pas 23 juin pour le dépôt 23 ans mais je
veux dire il l'a fait quand même un de
carrière il avait un profil qui était
pas du tout le profil habituel
c'est possible mais accéder aux plus
hautes sphères de l'état
ça c'est impossible il faut
impérativement avoir fait l'ena ou
polytechnique sciences po avant c'est ça
la réalité de la grande école école on a
un problème vis-à-vis du diplômé d'une
grande école vous en demande archers
républicaine finale monarchie
républicaine c'est qu'on est on est on
est face à des gens et d'ailleurs les
citoyens sont largement responsables ce
état de fait et citoyens se moquer de
jean pierre raffarin a par exemple qu'il
n'était pas un énarque qui ont qui ne
parlait pas comme l énarque et tous les
citoyens se moquer de lui en revanche
les citoyens adore les énarques
quand est ce que le parti de marine le
pen par exemple et de voeux à percer
dans l'est dans les dents et dans l'est
dans les sondages dans les élections à
m'intéresser à adjoindre un énarque qui
parle comme un énarque en rien finale au
félin phélippeau 2.2 sous parties etc
regardez tous les chefs de partis sont
tous des élus dire que ces apparats par
françois bayrou est effectivement chez
les verts existants les deux partis qui
auront fab et françois bayrou s'est pas
à partie alors comment échanger supprime
les grandes écoles est ce qu'on supprime
les grands corps et je crois que c'est
une contradiction polonaise absolument
formidable et qui va très loin
ce que derrière cette question des
grands corps elle est majeure moi je
connais pas tous les jours enfin trop
souvent des cas de blocage des
nominations en raison du fait que la
candidat le candidat n'est pas sorti des
grands corps les exemples sont multiples
mais derrière ça il ya un mythe français
qui est fragilisée puisque le mythe
française c'est quand même celui de la
république
la saga des siens or aujourd'hui ce
mythe est on y est
l'ascenseur social ne fonctionne plus et
cette question des corps elle est
autobloquantes pour toute la société
française est derrière moi je vois si on
va jusqu'au bout du raisonnement est
bien à chaque fois qu'on parle des
institutions françaises et à la question
de savoir si on doit aller vers un
régime parlementaire ou un régime
présidentiel et il ya un espèce de
tabous comme un préalable qui est que
les français sont attachés à l'élection
présidentielle et que donc on peut
penser ce qu'on veut sauf ne touchez à
cette pièce de l'édifice et derrière ça
la fonction pyramidale de l'élite se
reproduit quasiment pièces par kg à
l'are beaucoup d élèves à ce qu'elle
dure en est condamné à une société
verticalement
d'abord le premier problème il ya enfin
le premier prime c'est la consanguinité
effectivement le fait que toute la
classe politique cette entre eux soit
même où les actes aux marionnettes se
connaissent pas et c'est donc cette
consanguinité qui n'existe quasiment
qu'en france la ce stade ça c'est un
premier problème est un deuxième
problème n'y a pas de passerelle entre
la vraie vie entre le monde des
entreprises le monde syndical le monde
étudiant et c'était effectivement ce
sont des sociétés savall elle ne
résoudra pas pierre lemieux terreau pas
immédiate immédiate il ya longtemps
boris johnson ne serait pas possible
chez nous n'a cessé de s'impliquer
parisienne saint jean le maire de louga
wii et qui était inquiété et qui est
aidé dans mon ancien collègue ici il a
été correspondant pendant cinq ans à
bruxelles - le télégramme le deuxième
donc le deuxième problème c'est donc
l'absence de passerelle et le troisième
c'est que on voit des conflits
d'intérêts qui naissent de plus en plus
entre la haute fonction publique et la
haute fonction privée parce que les
pantouflages mais il ya pire que ça on
fait des allers-retours monsieur macron
il a été inspecteur général des finances
il part dans le privé il va dans une
donc et il revient comme ministre d'état
et elle se serait possible ailleurs par
exemple ça jean quatremer est ce que
d'autres pays permettrait en fait morte
ou flash non mais je veux dire que dans
tous les pays par exemple aux etats-unis
cette année anne nous exemple il est
clair que bon par exemple les gens qui
sortent de la ivy league c'est à dire
des grandes universités seront trop goût
au gouvernement du gouvernement passe
dans les médias dans les médias passent
dans les banques l'hystérie diallo dit
paul système c'est à dire que quand elle
quitte perdre une élection c'est fini
voilà il n'est pas le cas chez nous par
exemple quand on voit aujourd'hui la
première de la droite nicolas sarkozy
potentiellement françois fillon alain
juppé premier ministre en 95 ce serait
impensable ailleurs c'est ça ne
fonctionne pas comme ça ailleurs de la
même manière que ailleurs vous ne
verriez pas l'ancien directeur du trésor
devenir le patron de chez psa ou deux
pour reprendre un exemple de gauche
s'étaient élevées pour la droite et à
gauche et schmelzer qu'il fait la même
chose chez renault donc on passe sa
revanche des récents mois je crois que
sur la question de la fonction d'élu du
statut d'élu il ya des tabous qu'on n'a
pas réussi à lever jusqu'à présent par
exemple pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas
une règle sur la limite d'âge pour
l'élection pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas
un vrai statut de l'élu qui fait que
vous rentrez vous sortez et tout n'est
pas y compris dans cette affaire mme du
cumul on est aussi les champions
d'europe du cumul sur nous moi je sais
que au parti socialiste martine aubry
avait organisé un référendum au mode des
militants qui a été massivement soutenu
et cette réforme du cumul est toujours
pas en place et c'est ça aussi qui
polluent les gens les gens les citoyens
sont pas innocentes la mère soit vivante
indique pour que la loi interviennent là
dessus raison de plus pour que les
mandats soit limité dans l'espace et
dans le temps chez les écolos ça se
passe très bien ça tourne donc on a on
n'a pas de nom je parle de le
renouvellement des mandats électoraux et
tourne effectivement il ya d'autres
choses qui bloque
mais finalement c'est un peu logique
qu'on ait des occupations en place à
l'image de paul demos à la page à
l'image de l'écologie c'est pour revenir
et donne à la fois à semis à la fois des
jeunes femmes et des jeunes tout court
c'est à dire que on voit bien qu'avec le
renouvellement des mandats qu'elle que
soit après et on a souri tout à l'heure
mais la vérité c'est qu'on peut le faire
on peut le faire avec ses collants des
statuts et ça marche
et donc on a la capacité de le faire
dans les autres partis alors finalement
quand on voit ses occupations nous place
avec cette envie de renouvellement cette
envie de changement
est-ce qu'il faut pas s'attendre
effectivement est-ce que ça déclenche
quelque chose il faut l'espérer qu'il
soit un élément déclencheur mais ce qui
s'est passé au cours des 15 dernières
années montre que ce n'a jamais ça tue
tout était un fake pas lorsqu'on a
retiré le cpe
ça s'est terminé du jeu aux laonnois là
et est ce que la situer les regardais ce
qui s'est passé avec podemos en espagne
finalement simon et n'ose même pas que
des étudiants et des lycéens c'est de
l'ensemble de la société qui se révolter
contre sa classe politique qui avait
mené le pays à la faillite
la france n'en est pas là la france
n'est pas encore assez dans la crise
française le vote front national
et c'est bien plus grave voilà où il
faut je rêve d'un pot demos hélas ce que
nous avons français front national sur
la place du front national je pense qu
il ya quelque chose de très spécifique à
la france a c'est le renouvellement
politique finalement ce front national
celle interne en aidant les intervenants
devraient donner cette situation alors
qu'on est quand même un pays où il ya
des choses absolument formidable qui se
passe et je dis retour a salué le succès
de la coop 21 de la conférence sur le
climat et la coupe et le le changement
climatique ça a été un succès qui a été
porté par donc c'est que c'est possible
finale mais quelle est aujourd'hui la
transformation de sa caisse que ça
imprimé dans le pays
finalement c'est à dire finalement donc
aujourd'hui un problème c'est que
derrière il faut mais je répète le
problème de la france c'est sa capacité
à mettre la société royale og en débat
et effectivement quand il ya des
blocages et les gamins ont eu raison de
se révolter contre le cpe parce que ça
portait atteinte à leur dignité
simplement derrière il y a eu tort le
gouvernement n'a pas été en capacité
d'essayer de proposer autre chose
il doit pas être simplement dans le
refus et dans le blocage bon il faut
réformer
il faut débattre il faut se respecter
c'est ça le blocage la la rance d'abord
et avant tout alors on verra bien ce que
ça donne d'ici quelques semaines
on verra ça dans la rue merci à tous
merci à vous d'avoir participé à ce
débat merci à vous nous avoir éclairé
vous retrouver la semaine prochaine
ahmed tazir depuis strasbourg quant à
nous c'est fini
ciao